he smoked at lunch with his [ __ ] nose
well you see butt cleavage maybe you see
the bottom of cheeks he has to now
physically pull his penis out of the new
body I immediately got the taste of soy
sauce all right Gary tell us what's
going on for clean out the computer day
so Michael Rapaport sin our fantasy
football league has been a league for a
long time he's always a major pain in
the ass he made it to the finals this
year for the third time and he lost
right
he was a loss to Richard how much did
you win in that fantasy for 1200 yeah
the sweetest victory is getting to beat
Michael Rapaport and the championship
awesome like he calls Garry and JD all
the time and like screams at them JD
Sunday morning you know what that means
right it's time for [ __ ] I've been
[ __ ] every single person in this
league does he do that with you I won't
give him my number
I won't by four years he's tried he's
begged Sal for my number
Sal gives it gave him lunch the number
so he can yell e yeah and I don't need
that I don't need somebody yelling at me
on my personal time I usually don't like
to mix it up with him but after Richard
beat him I texted AA sponsor
I couldn't resist what you saying I said
oh the humanity lost again you're the
Susan Lucci of this league I couldn't
take right back [ __ ] you no no it's more
like um he goes into this weird mood
where it's just like can't you see I'm
in mourning right now
after he lost he'd have Richards numbers
but he didn't have Sal's number so he
left Sal 'voice male but mostly he just
picked on me you got hit yeah boomerang
[ __ ] law school and now I got that
big tooth [ __ ] ate that Boone [ __ ]
Bowie texted me and talk to me in
harassing me that [ __ ] animal did you
see it picked her for a Rockefeller
Center
how dare he poses in front of a
Christmas tree with those [ __ ] yellow
teeth [ __ ] the people were running for
their lives it's fear behind him and
he's got the [ __ ] nerve to be
harassing me wow you you got under his
skin I like that so what happened next
so what happened next is now it's time
to get paid because he did win as a
runner-up you get some money it might be
two or three hundred bucks right $400
yeah okay so we had the wrong email
address for him not offer he changes
email address and didn't tell us so the
money got sent somewhere he ends up
getting his money but at this point in
his voicemail he hasn't got his money
yet and he's threatening people I
guarantee you that that cow [ __ ] was
Kristi got his money okay and then
everybody else was getting paid
throughout the year but I can't get my
[ __ ] money now so what are you a
[ __ ] church you can't answer the
phone prick what do you suggest
oh Jesus Christ needs to point hundred
that quick huh he wants his money do you
love it out in California with the legal
yeah Colorado - you know what you think
we've been legal in Cali if you ask me
what's the thing gummies or all that
gummies and what do you do first of all
that's for [ __ ] [ __ ] no I don't I
don't do [ __ ] we smoke we smoke it
don't eat candies and [ __ ] like No I
smoke weak what have you ever smoked
with other celebrities because they seem
to get the strong weed that like knock
you on you I got a crazy story for you I
got it okay this is way before SNL just
when I was just doing kid sister and I I
got the chance to smoke weed with Snoop
and Don wine yeah Don Juan bishop
one and I'm not paying attention to to
don wine I'm not paying attention to
what he's doing to the blunts he's
smoking them with his [ __ ] nose why
cuz I guess there's a hole in his nose
and he can hit it I don't [ __ ] know
so he was doing it from a nose and I
wasn't paying attention nobody was
hitting that [ __ ] but I was in your
mouth Super Bowl is this Sunday Super
Bowl Sunday time does it start the game
itself black on started at 6:18 I think
is when they kick off but the pregame
starts at like 11:00 in the morning it's
ridiculous there's just countless a lot
of talk are you gonna root for the
Chiefs uh I think I might root for
Kansas because they have a 1 in 50 50
years but then nothing would please me
more to watch you [ __ ] weep more if
they win yeah I think I want Kansas
actually I don't know why I'm weird with
you you promised me a shower if you if I
can win of course yeah if they win you
shower every day ok that's a deal you
like rooting against the Chiefs right
Robin yeah because I want to see Richard
devastate can I just say go cheese let's
do this
Kansas City we've been waiting 50
well tell the Chiefs fans what you want
to say we'll be quiet this has never
happened in my [ __ ] lifetime and I've
been lifelong Chiefs fan man we're doing
this Kansas City thank you Bob they can
be read Thank You [ __ ] Travis Kelce
thank you honey badger thank you Frank
Clark you guys are the [ __ ] best you
made me so happy this year this is gonna
[ __ ] rule if you win I'm gonna be so
[ __ ] happy so thank you Chiefs you
[ __ ] rule let's hear it Kansas said
hey why is just so important you in
other words is it because Kansas City is
really not caught up it's not a big this
is your chance to map and you know
everybody's like Oh Richard you root for
the Eagles too I root for the Eagles
because of my wife my wife grew up an
Eagles fan right so I'll root for the
Eagles for my wife but I grew up of
Chiefs van Chiefs Royals k UJ oxide you
wanna know I'll get you crying your dad
oh my god yeah he'll talk about what the
Chiefs mean to your dad
always lived on his whole life on a farm
what my dad and I grew up watching the
Chiefs together every Sunday we bonded
over James we bond over the [ __ ]
Royals my dad took me to so many Royals
games we could never afford to go to the
Chiefs games but we watched together at
home and and your dad is getting older
you're getting older and how many more
Chiefs games there are exactly and I
told Patrick mahomes when I talked to
him last year I said I just I would love
for my dad and I just see achieve Super
Bowl together wow what an emotion that
just came out of you yeah this is I
can't even describe the emotions of
going to you who do you who you call
first your father if they my dad yeah
and I'll I'll be crying my eyes out
let's take you dad
no let's hear the conversation the
Chiefs have just won the Super Bowl and
I go hello
dead hi Richard hey buddy how about them
trade how about them cheese this we did
waiting when it happened could you
believe it you remember when we first
started what and let hey we used to
cheer for Cristiano koi a the Nigerian
nightmare my dad and I got to meet him
together when we met then man Cristiano
koi
oh my god and now here now it happened
now it once we did and we're gonna keep
winning it doesn't end here
I'll be talking to you later Bob okay I
love you so much dad go chiefs how about
them chief how bout them change Richard
and I hope you remembered not to shower
I don't care what that filthy Howard
Stern I'm never gonna wash away these
tears they're all right listen that's
emotional and you're real men because
you can show your emotion thank you I've
cried over a lot of stuff what will he
be if they lose oh my god you know what
I'm gonna be like I'm gonna be bummed
but I know as long as my homes is coming
back we're gonna get there eventually
but I think this is a year this is it
this is it for all Chiefs fan
what type of loser is JD had a weed
gummy this weekend and then I said to
mom how much was in it you know there's
a this the amount of the grams milligram
said he was worried when we went to LA
how many Milligan he goes I don't even
know where I loose a little bit and pry
it a little too much and I don't like to
be out of control and this is like one
of those rare times where I stupidly let
myself out of control a little bit
he had a margarita which is a margarita
infused with weed honey
okay weed gummies and three bottles of
wine in addition to the margarita what I
didn't have like three bottles all the
way so well you split it with one other
person
sure one bottle of wine is about seven
drinks JD I don't do the math I just do
the drinking no surprise here JD got
very buzzed mm-hmm then agreed to be
interviewed while he was inebriated we
started by asking JD when was the last
time he that he cried when was the last
time you cried oh I cry all the time
right right now like right now I'm Terry
no see why are you tearing I don't know
what is making I don't know like maybe
when I get self introspective or
something yeah but I mean I've drinking
a margarita so maybe that's part of it I
don't know are you mixing up crying with
your eyes watering well that's I don't
know that's there's something going on
with Reed I just I don't know or I ever
realize yet I cried when Capote lay with
clothes and I was hungry at this point
the edibles and the wine were really
kicking in and so of course they started
asking him about his coworkers um who's
your favorite and least favorite staff
members my favorite server
well John Heinz probably my best friend
Jason Kaplan least favorite cuz he's the
biggest mark its biggest staff nark
described Chris Wilding in a few words
smiling yeah look he likes attention
Christ okay describe Gary Dell'Abate in
a few words
yeah Gary Tawaf a talkative
um [ __ ] dogs are going I describe will
in a few words well the few words I
cannot agree I wonder who would
cantankerous
lovable but also
it'll be a double he just came here he
can give you an attitude if I'm calling
will Louisville one definitely [ __ ] up
here he is sniffing his wine glass and
stuffing his face oh we saw him finish
this Riesling Jesus it's almost like a
less sweet apple juice
while ago we need very good tools and
some cheese good JD was so drunk and
stoned that he wanted to do some karaoke
you want to hear that I can pass it up
this [ __ ] couch right
[Music]
[Music]
there's JD doing thriller do you
remember any of this like the drips and
drabs
[Music]
JD's wild it was crowded mouth it was
just one night I felt comfortable in my
surroundings and you know I had fun
thank goodness you don't feel
comfortable very often I touch him yeah
all right all right thanks Eric by the
way his his passion for Wilding is
reaching a very very creepy level right
he called me the other day and broke
down this whole fantasy he has about him
and wildin but the weird part is they're
not having sex in this fantasy he wants
a projector screen to flash up a picture
of his ceiling and what's Chris wearing
in the picture a pair of shorts that
chested and that's it why - what's up do
you want his [ __ ] to be falling out of
the bottom of the short shorts yes all
right he said he wanted him oiled up -
and he wanted his hair wet Eric do you
now see that you're possibly gay no I'm
not
how can you say that you want a
projection of Chris Wilding there's [ __ ]
balls in your face
I would say it's ostensibly to jerk off
- am i correct yeah when he looks at the
picture what do you imagine when you're
jerking off to Chris what are you
thinking is happening I hope that it
touches me that I touch him so you want
Chris to reach into your lap and play
with your penis during sex mistreat him
candy and then he play with it and you
play with his penis and he plays with
your penis but eric has a problem with
his penis Howard he has to now
physically pull his penis out of his
body it's yeah you know retract yeah he
wants to come in and show you that you
want to come in and show me your
retracted penis retracted Peter Chris
you you want for that yeah I mean I want
to wear like you know medical medical
gloves maybe like a hazmat suit
I'll book Eric okay Gary you're gonna
take care of that Eric we'll get a day
we'll come down here you'll go digging
for his penis week loves on okay yes
what are you looking forward to that's
right ladies and gentlemen I want you to
be here big joke of it up when we dig
for Eric's Peters Chris is covered in
the and we'll be playing from the top
500 songs of the year I have to ask you
about this hacking thing that you took
nude pictures and I guess who hacked you
I don't even know I was getting
blackmailed by a dude I met on match.com
no [ __ ] oh my god that's horrible no
[ __ ] [ __ ] you went out on the date
with this guy and I did never met the
[ __ ] I didn't realize getting
catfished oh I was getting catfished
I didn't [ __ ] realize do you know I
end up being a 10 euro in and
[ __ ] I think it was some other words
somebody saw Leslie Jones is on one of
these things
which means they were posing as somebody
else and I was talking to this
[ __ ] and everything you know
when you realize you're being hacked
right and you've sent somebody these
pictures who do you call okay take us
through it first first what happened was
whoever got it [ __ ] put it up on on a
site and so I called I didn't even know
TMZ called my phone oh my god TMZ karma
for names like yeah this TMZ so what'd
you feel about the new pictures I was
like what they put your phone number and
your passport now I was like wait I get
my phone or my passport I said [ __ ] you
call the number so I hung up and I
called my publicist were you in a panic
pictures I was more panic about them
having my phone number and my passport
absolutely didn't [ __ ] new packet
give a [ __ ] about the new pitch I've
been trying to get them out there anyway
and you don't hear your whole life you
waiting to be famous you get famous and
now all I could think was Lauren's gonna
[ __ ] kill me that's Lauren's gonna
[ __ ] kill me so Lauren Roseman the
publicist she's [ __ ] the [ __ ] she got
it off in 20 minutes right how she's a
badass [ __ ] she got it off so then she
the first thing we do is go to the
security team then they take you to
Homeland Security
cuz Homeland Security was like oh he's
in another country we found a briefing
to get his ass if could they get it they
say if I would have been calm maybe
because I went to [ __ ] off
but then what end up happening was we
were working with the FBI did they want
you to do a sting where you would have
gotten of these guys yeah like I was on
the phone with you were in calm enough I
was not calm enough because the
[ __ ] got arrogant he was like I
was like alright so how much do you want
he was like yeah you need to send 25,000
to this then I was like it's really
[ __ ] up dude whether he was like you
know what let's make it 35,000 sounds
like oh I was like you know what use a
piece of [ __ ]
they're like I thought she was an
actress what else you got
so then you know he lives in New York
City sometimes and sometimes there's a
lot of construction going on so this is
I love this he puts us on Instagram the
video they'll be working outside his
apartment he just starts screaming at
all the workers they don't [ __ ] stop
what kind of real it is real oh my god
he's got every right in the world to
feel that way yeah but he's like on the
15th floor he's a tough guy
yeah he's yelling they can't hear I
don't know that he'd yell at them like
that I think they can hear what are you
guys gonna be done here the [ __ ]
building down man oh my god imagine
being his neighbor
what are the weird bets oh there's quite
a few profits coming in this week let's
start off with the first song that's
gonna be performed this is an actual bed
Ike this is an actual bet you can make
that J Lo's first song will be what the
odds are four plus four hundred which
means if you bet $100 you win $400 it's
going to be on the floor
[Music]
you must like this JD cuz it's like EDM
kinda is I don't I don't like a lot of
like singing with the the electronic
music I'm ready to sing so
[Music]
[Music]
go ahead
so is pitbull coming well there's a prop
for that I say pitbulls coming pitbull
shows up on stage during halftime -200
yes plus 150 I said take that bet
yeah but wouldn't pitbull like bet on
himself if he knew like how do you keep
him from betting on himself they don't
let you bet like a million dollars you
could get inside information but that DJ
Khalid is he dropped for him all the
other one is will a rod be shown during
the half I say no I'll say 50 they don't
show a rod during the actual problem
another JLo prop yeah will you see butt
cleavage no yes or no
you mean ass crack no - 404 no plus 254
yes I say nobody ever shown is closely I
don't think no yeah no I like maybe you
see the bottom of cheeks under shorts
but I don't think you're gonna see that
either yeah let's jump over to Shakira
real quick cuz you could better her
first song as well and you've got a
column there she wolf is the favorite of
plus 250 that's the first this is the
favorite yes
[Music]
whatever wherever is +400 like what does
that mean if I bet a hundred bucks
you'll win 400 if I hit that that seems
like I should get a lot more money if I
can predict Shakira's playlist for tawon
is what they said all right so let me
hear I think there's a good shot the
next one at plus 600 hips don't lie
no she's gonna wait on that no she has a
little time yeah you always try to
finish she's a part of it she's not it's
not J dude you're gonna lose money go
ahead and bet it no I don't so why don't
you make a bet my song should carry
those come on put your money where your
mouth is
God knows where your mouth you know all
right I'll go fifty with you all right
no way hips no lies or first all right
so Howard and Robin fifty gave me action
are you on action - I'll give Robin
action that was fire duty you won those
edibles margarita yeah I actually see
his logic in this thank you John I win
see it's gonna be in the middle of J
Lo's performance she's gonna come in or
you think she's gonna want to really uh
those horns maybe you got a point away I
could lose for JLo to change outfits you
see a Doritos at first or a pop-tarts at
first
I'll take torito's 400 bucks I think
these what would you say I'll take pop
time all right how much oh hey JD oh why
do you want in I kind of a little bit
what do you think
I think Doritos will well sure I know
his mother take a bet with Robin all
right Robin if you want action on that
okay who are you taking to eat I'm
taking Doritos so we're both my pet both
going against Robin smart bet I took it
Gary's got the home theater experience
now so he's like yeah inviting everyone
over yeah like every minute how many
seats are in the theater eight seats and
three stools you got to sit on the stool
for the Super Bowl
no you could do whatever you want
there's a stool in the theater it's two
rows yeah go close up and then the back
row there's like a bar like a piece of
granite and their stools I they're very
comfortable stools i7 they are in a home
theater it's not it's not a bar it's
like a uh you put a couch or something
on the back because I built the one I
wanted not what you want no but isn't it
more comfortable there's eight seats
that's what I wanted the whole
excitement of a home theater is that
you're in a comfortable chain right but
you can also sit back there and you can
have drinks and you can eat and you know
that's the experience that I want well
it's a [ __ ] up experience because it's
not your house I'm gonna be any good the
[ __ ] theater want to eagle you kitchen
right that's what you would do because
you got far too many chairs go across or
like know exactly I'm stupid why do you
care what's in it exactly
doop no because it's not what you think
first of all it's incredibly comfortable
the stools that they're not referring
back on high back leather chairs I satin
up for the other week and they're very
comfortable sat instead of sitting in
the comfortable chair well cuz I had a
bunch of people over this is the whole
thing this is another one so you
couldn't even get the good chair my wife
is like well we invited people around
like [ __ ] them let them sit there listen
what I'll tell you why I'm right he's
right now you are right [ __ ] I want to
sit in my comfortable chairs records
know and rightly so she goes our guests
should get the comfortable chair you sit
in the shitty chair why why should there
be a shitty chair but you didn't a story
into the story it turned out it was very
comfortable yeah sure now I know you're
missing the point you're all missing
here's the point again was he he rips
out those schools are you excited couch
here's the point imagine a nice if you
were just [ __ ] talk you don't we go
to screening rooms we were fortunate
enough a couple of times to be asked by
movie studios to see a movie ahead of
time we'd go in the building and then
you'd have these incredibly comfortable
leather couches
chairs and I have unbelievably
comfortable leather chairs unbelievably
calm yeah but you can be moving around I
grab my good chair understand why you
have a man cave that's where you're
supposed to watch Super Bowl know you're
watching it in the theater yeah that
won't be dumb to watch it on 130 inch
screen Robin I agree no I think it's
great but I just think the chair thing
is beyond every room the [ __ ] you want
except for you to come to my [ __ ]
house Gary I'm just saying I guarantee
that in the future you rip that out
you're wrong couch it you're wrong we
love it we've been there we love it
we put some food up there people go back
and have them use it Natalie you sit you
sit at that little marble I haven't it's
not it's fine but I don't want you
sitting in the comfortable chairs no no
it's a rarity that it's full okay you're
damn saying all right where's our you're
sitting in the stools for Super Bowl I
don't know where I'm throwing a party so
I'll be moving all around he'll be in
the man cares eight there's eight chairs
that's but he could have twelve chairs
and steady push I don't like a place
from the e I actually don't know that we
could how many places he need to feed
well it's not all about me believe it or
not sometimes you want to entertain
people judging by the size of you it's
about you
[Music]
you boys ready to try this I mean I'm
not ready look it says it here on the
internet where every true thing is guys
are making videos of themselves dipping
their balls in soy sauce claiming they
can taste the salt we're gonna
experiment see if you can tell the
difference between water and I want to
get my dick in that soy sauce just your
balls cover our balls gonna be black
looking at your balls in it that would
be Tim Flannery
the question is will you shower when you
go home whatever's on all five times
there is a new internet trend where men
are dipping their balls in soy sauce
so in front of us we have soy sauce now
how's this gonna work Gary um so what's
gonna happen so I'll go first sounds
gonna put a blindfold put on your
blindfold blindfold and then I'm just
gonna pick I'm gonna have to do both and
he's gonna have to tell me which one was
which all right give it a shot you ready
so I'm ready all right I'm gonna kill
this music Freddie just because I really
don't want to miss a thing you know okay
I can't see so can you lift your dick up
no you lift your dick up yes you don't
you ready yeah oh it's cold all right is
it soy sauce wow you won't believe this
I immediately I immediately got the
taste of soy sauce are you serious I
swear to God it went through my nostrils
and all my taste buds Gary is that in
fact soy sauce no its water
give me the soy sauce let's see if I can
taste it even more
the water was amazing good good water
your ball right now this this is why are
you sniffing think it's so strong in the
nose you taste anything no how would I
could taste absolutely not let's try it
on Richard and by the way Oh such a
strong smell in here Richard did you
bathe recently Sunday I did and what is
today Tuesday yeah you got an odor yeah
I caught a whiff it's it's it's Ahlers
or it's him he told me didn't shower why
Richard why not shower if it's all good
yes no time at all no he's so busy yeah
what you're grabbing two year old son
Gary you gotta wait for him to put the
blindfold on Gary just grabbed a cup and
showed it to Richard I didn't see it
luckily all right now yeah put your put
your blindfold on Gary what's with you
don't worry you pull them I don't think
you know what you do
I think Richard or maybe I'll hold
Richard's notes because the smell gives
it away Howard so alright hold it you
don't know [ __ ] take a shower and keep
Gary Gary lift my dick up oh yeah Gary's
gonna have to lift the lift up you dick
I want Gary to do oh okay it's cold his
balls are in the solution I I don't
taste anything I mean I better that's oh
oh now get a little salt right give it
give it give it a second let's see what
happens leave your balls and they in the
solution huh yeah I'm getting a little
salty taste sensation I think that's the
soy sauce Gary it is the soy sauce Wow
Richard has taste buds in his bowl you
know what it is and what I think would
that happen with Sal you got to leave it
in there for a minute do you really feel
you could taste some salty since okay
yeah I felt a weird like not really a
taste but like something soaking in my
balls that tingled it a little get out
of here now go wash your balls off in
the sink good job boys the soy sauce
covers up my stink idli yeah it did help
[Music]
the Howard Stern Show